nick is with us in Grand Rapids Michigan
hi Nick welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up um my wife and I are in
our mid-30s
we have about $30,000 in debt we make
about 90,000 a year I'm in real estate
school right now also working my job and
my wife for the last seven years has
been doing cpa work and she wants to go
back to school to get her CPA and we
want to cashflow it we have about 3000
and savings that was part of your
program that we've we've been doing for
the last few years can you give me any
advice on that
advice on one on being able to cash flow
that wild paying off the debt that we
have okay you make ninety thousand
dollars a year and she's been doing CPA
work for how long
accounting work for a home seven about
seven years okay and I think her going
back to school and getting her CPA is a
wonderful goal and I would do it next
year after you're out of debt okay
we don't own a house or anything we've
we made a thousand-mile move so that's
why we're renting a house right now good
we pay about 1,200 a month good rent
good most of our debt student loans and
one card note is what we have so much do
there are about ten thousand okay you
make ninety thousand yeah you're
debt-free in one year okay
thirty thousand twenty-five hundred a
month then you're free you can breathe
build your emergency fund and cash flow
her school but you're trying to do three
things at once and when you try to do
three things
once none of them work there is nothing
on fire here except her emotions
she's been an accountant for seven years
so she's an accountant for eight years
before she gets her CPA instead of seven
years it's not a big deal it's a good
choice it's not a good choice in the
situation you all are in you need to
finally focus on this debt you've been
screwing around the edges of this and
you haven't hammered it how much debt
have you paid off so far and in what
period of time
he's probably paid off about 10,000 in
the last couple years yeah
see what I mean yeah that's just
completely what's a fight making a 90
grand you paid off five thousand dollars
a year for two years that's sneezing you
follow me I show you're these people
come on here do their debt-free screams
you don't have anybody say I paid on
five thousand dollars a year making
ninety thousand you don't ever hear that
when they're doing the debt free scream
do you they paid out thirty thousand a
year make it 90 thousand so now it's
time now you guys you don't have to do
Dave Ramsey's plan you don't have to get
out of that you can live and be you know
do your life she can go back to school
you keep this to the card that keep it
stick around around next 20 years you
can do all that you'll just be normal
but and I'm gonna be mad at you you're
still be my friend
you'll just be one of my broke friends
and I got a lot of them so but if you
want to do the stuff we're talking about
it's time for you all to turn up the
heat it's time for you all to get really
mad about this situation and quit trying
to 73 things at once because you have
you still eating out you're still going
on vacation you're not doing a good
budget you just wandering around the
field out here
hoping you can find the fence you know
it's time to get laser intense
emotionally focused and if you do that
you can clear this debt in one year then
she goes to school you'll knock that CPA
out and I agree with her goal I I think
it's a great you know it's great field
of study great tool to have in your belt
and it'll probably upper-income a good
bet to be able to do that all of that
would be great but it's it's you know
it's just symptomatic of the way you all
been doing this so far so this is the
day you decide what are you gonna do you
can keep doing the way you've been doing
it you're gonna keep getting what you've
been getting or you're gonna do
something different it's up to you you
get to choose that's the beauty god
gives you the dignity to choose you have
the right to choose and I'll give you
the same dignity you have the right to
choose but you call me and ask me for
advice which means you're gonna get my
advice that's how that works